on ne peut pas admettre c'est qu'on
interdise de fumer dans un bar tabac
alors qu'on a des produits qu'on vend
sont des produits légaux à puisque de
par notre être et de gérance moment
s'est produit légalement il est
buraliste sont en colère et ils le font
savoir une centaine d'entre eux a
manifesté cet après midi devant la
préfecture de montpellier
il conteste le décret du gouvernement
interdisant de fumer dans tous les lieux
publics
un décret qui sera étendue au 1er
janvier 2008 au bar tabac les buralistes
estiment une perse de leurs activités à
au moins 30%
même inquiétude du côté de perpignan les
manifestants ont sillonné les rues
catalan banderoles et revendications en
main le cortège c'est là encore arrêté
devant la préfecture
les buralistes attendent désormais des
propositions concrètes du gouvernement
vous comprenez qu'il est très difficile
pour nos de leur côté et de leur
interdire de les fumer de l'autre
voilà d'autant plus
l'endroit est convivial et beaucoup de
gens fument ce sera difficile parce
qu'on sorte les buralistes espère
désormais l'ouverture de négociations
ils demandent un délai de quatre à cinq
ans pour mettre leur établissement en
conformité avec la loi une loi qui les
autorise à mettre en place mais fumoir
ils demandent également des aides
supplémentaires dans le cadre du contrat
d'avenir
un contrat qui leur permet déjà de
toucher une aide de 150 millions d'euros
par an et demi en place suite à
l'augmentation des prix du tabac